Kevin I don't want you to look over
there but there is a guy next to you
making obscene gestures on stage don't
look don't look don't look
security
[ __ ] you I found a new partner
we got a dude here who's signing for
some folks in the crowd who can't hear
so if if you hear somebody if you hear
this at one point that's the sign
language dude passing out yeah from the
overwork we're doing and the amount of
new terms he has to figure out how to I
don't envy him yeah like let's test it
out rectal fist [ __ ]
[Applause]
[ __ ] I could have done that fair enough
alright let's see if we can go a little
more subtle how about how about this one
give that penis a sandwich don't like it
I'm having SAT moms go do that
a lot of times I get happy during the
show and I described myself as being
enthusiastic I say Skeet Skeet Skeet
[Applause]
intl dude you could just walk up to deaf
people and be like skeet skeet skeet and
they'll know exactly what you mean
they'll call for a cop but they'll know
exactly what you mean I think you just
did confetti
this is skeet skeet skeet this is
confetti it's got to go this way I can't
go out now I don't think so cuz I think
then you get to do this sign
speak for yourself dude it's my own [ __ ]
so I'm like this I want to use these
start wiping off right now they calls me
pac-man
they calls me pac-man it's this sign
language I used to think oh it's so
mysterious who can do it
pac-man is literally a walk away Eggman
I know half the language already sign
language thing's a scam I'm figuring
well we have some hearing impaired
people here tonight because the Deaf are
our biggest audience for our podcast
they love it they can't get enough of it
they just sit there staring at their
iPhones oh these guys just like I don't
get it
somebody likes them welcome to Hollywood
babble-on
right here in San Juan Capistrano
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]